within Israel particularly among the
more Orthodox Jews and also among the
Evangelical American Community for
religious reasons they want the capital
of Israel to be Jerusalem right now
politically Jerusalem is disputed so the
internationally the capital of Israel is
Tel Aviv the people who want to just
push the embassy to Jerusalem it doesn't
change the capital but it's a signal
it's sort of like saying we view
Jerusalem as the capital because that's
where we're putting the embassy it sends
a signal of like we don't actually care
to resolve the conflict around Jerusalem
we're just going to put the embassy
there anyway so it in Flames it doesn't
work towards peace it arguably works
against it yeah so that's something he
did it didn't get us closer to peace you
know so I think the thing on Trump is
very confused
um you know confused about uh North
Korea confused about China didn't
understand how tariffs worked all these
things but fortunately he didn't
actually accomplish a lot of the things
he tried to do and I think we're better
off for it